you if you talk about if you if you
mention something like you know the
healing thing and it's a toxic guy to me
all that says is that guy had an impact
on you in it like no matter how she's
trying to act like yeah you know I've
healed him different now I'm thinking
yeah yo yeah but my 50 years my death
but she's gonna be like yeah but I just
want to talk to him one more time
that's what that means still I think
this idea of you can definitely
heal
um and retain you know a lot of your
value but I think you have to have the
right mindset and today people are so
self-obsessed that they they take it
into the more the ego driven bit so
every time they're healed they're like
I'm better I'm better now I'm better I
deserve more and it's like no you're not
in fact you know you deserve laughs